[Music]
okay so an important thing to understand
with Aikido training is that you have to
always be keeping the distance that's
what working to do now if we have
perfect Aikido and the perfect ability
then they could never break that
distance and they could never touch us
right and this is like the the fame
19:25 about that you wish you had
against the swordsman where the
swordsmen got so frustrated he threw
down his sword because he just never
could land a clean strike on you but
right so he was able to keep that
distance so cleanly that the guy could
never break it down however if you don't
have perfect IQ which I certainly don't
then sometimes that distance is going to
break down and if that distance breaks
down you're gonna be looking for
suppression and burying a line changing
the line that you're on and that was the
last video where we talked about the
basic idea of that so now let's look at
how we're gonna vary that line in Aikido
we have six movements that are called
the Tai no pinko the variation in
positions and those variation positions
give us an advantage over the other
person so when they're attacking and
they've crushed that line these six give
us an advantage so jongshin's economy
for me right here like this there are
six basic ways to move 45 so I'm going
to keep the same lead foot and move it a
45 degree angle triangle I'm gonna go to
a 45 degree angle and switch my lead
foot 90
I'm gonna go 90 degrees to Josh while
keeping the inside of me open to Josh I
mean he's where I am strongest I don't
want to stand at 90 like this because
he's at my back that's not where ideally
want to have him my 90 has him right
here in front of me I soak the Waring
which is an outside turn I turn to the
outside of JA this way
poochy more inside turn I turn to the
inside of Josh this way and he knee me
where I attempt to enter straight in
behind Josh and that's what we're
looking for
those 60 I know Rico can be done either
in I'm on Mir Johan me this is Johan me
meaning we have opposite feet forward
okay so he has his right foot forward I
have my left
I can bury this we can also do those six
from I hung me as well so these right
foot forward and my right foots bored so
we sell it the same 45 triangle 90
Guinea
soap so mawari and Gucci mortar and
these six tiny Winco are the foundations
for all the rest of everything we'll do
in Aikido if it breaks down this far
they're also basically the ideas we do
when we're at a distance so whether I'm
circling around to the outside or
entering but in behind them whatever it
is I'm trying to do that's basically the
same ideas we're gonna work with now if
you look at modern sport fighting these
tiny Linko maybe don't make a lot of
sense right so if it's just Josh and I
boxing you can understand why a 45 would
be a good idea you maybe even can
understand in switching stances why a
triangle might be a good idea what I
want to change my stance when I'm doing
that 90s may be a little stranger but
maybe for some reason I might want to
make this position something like soap
the more it seems totally bizarre and a
sport fight right why would they do that
eating me in most sport bikes is also
not a great idea you might be able to
get away with the MMA but in boxing it's
not really a great idea because if I
enter all the way back here I can't hit
him back like this so that doesn't do us
any good and who chew or it also seems
like a really weird idea why would I do
that kind of action so why would I do
those things you gotta understand Aikido
is always based with the idea that there
are multiple attackers so it's not just
me and this guy there's someone else
involved as well right so if I'm dealing
with Josh being able to see if there's
anyone behind me is going to be
unnecessary step in fact the other
person could be coming in to engage with
me and I have to turn this way in order
to deal with that guy while Josh and I
are struggling if I'm in close getting
behind Josh is to save this place to be
so this is where I want to be to protect
myself
if josh has prevented me from going
outside meaning his arms wide so I can't
go outside
I might have to turn the inside in order
to get around this guy and that's why we
have each award so understanding these
basic Cuttino hiko will help you
understand the foundation of the rest of
Aikido after this we have a tendency in
Aikido to get up
with the techniques and think oh the
goal is to do a Sheol noggin is someone
or the goal is to KO to guide someone or
or something like that the goal in
Aikido is to be free those other
techniques will arise because he's
endangering my freedom he's locked me
down in some way that it's real hard for
me to get where I want to get so those
six times a week are how we're going to
bury the line suppression basically with
the idea of ego is how we're going to
get into there that starts to take us
into Aikido techniques next we're going
to look at some Aikido techniques